[Music]
no they're never just bones
it's all part of history it's all part
of the world's history
majority of people don't know we're here
the facility it's custom made to build
dinosaurs
my name is peter may and i build
dinosaur skeletons for museums
throughout the world
i'm the owner president of research
casting international we have 50 000
square feet we can handle the biggest
skeletons in the world
t-rex mastodons
allosaurs
we've mounted and displayed and built
right around 800 skeletons
[Music]
in a back room we have 50 skeletons
sitting in crates
when the skeleton arrives it'll be
uncrated unpacked and then it'll go into
the conservation department it'll be
cleaned and hardened and any of the old
consolidates removed so it's nice and
strong it comes to blacksmiths they
hammer out the armatures once all the
armatures are done then we go to
mounting
all in all they'll probably be about a
crew of ten that will handle the fossils
the car so the skeleton crew
we're doing a pair of skeletons right
now the driptasaurs and they're probably
one of the most dynamic poses you'll
ever see there's two dryptosaurs like
leaping in the air one on his back one
leaping down on top of it
we built the two big skeletons in the
first movie jurassic park the the
rearing barris art the american museum
of natural history
for the smithsonian we're helping them
rebuild all their exhibits all the
fossil animal exhibits
our job is to bring the old skeletons to
life
i think when fossils arrive here we
become the caretaker nothing can happen
to it and every person is handled along
the way understands that responsibility
by the time it's finished it comes out a
much better
fossil than when it arrived when it goes
on exhibit at the museum it's going to
last for another 100 years
[Music]
[Music]
pop quiz you need some info on the
futalankosaurus the barosuchus and the
daisynodon where do you go wikipedia
thanks nobomichi oh no problem how do we
know what these prehistoric creatures
look like
lots of careful research and attention
to details
how do you know i draw them wait really
all of them well a lot of them
this is nobumichi tamura hello and he's
got a pretty cool day job i'm working at
the advanced light source lawrence
berkeley national laboratory and my job
here is to take care of this machine
this micro diffraction and station the
micro defrag what micro diffraction and
station ah
but it's at night and on weekends that
nobu channels the scientific know-how
into his dinosaur drawings it's called
paliowat
my bad
paleoart is an original artistic
creation that depicts prehistoric life
according to the latest research right
nobu exactly it's a combination of
science and creativity so i basically
read the latest discovery on prehistoric
animals based on that i draw them this
is what i've been doing for the last
eight years and nibble's got a lot to
show for it by his estimate he's
published over 1500 drawings including
some in this book that he co-authored
but it wasn't always smooth sailing the
first drawing that was one of a dinosaur
called cosmosaurus but it was taken out
by the editors because it wasn't
accurate enough
that's okay nobu can't bat a thousand is
that the baseball reference i'm french
i got it not every baguette can be
perfect
we're done here
[Music]
sally sells seashells by the seashore i
sell seashells by the seashore
sally sells seashells by the seashore
sally sells seashells by the seashore
and sally was a real person
this is mary anning
she sold rare invertebrate fossils by
the seashore
born in 1799 mary was something
exceptionally rare for a woman at the
time
possibly because as an infant she was
struck by lightning no she really was
she was a paleontologist a fossil hunter
if you will
when she was 12 mary dug up a 200
million year old marine reptile the
echosaurus skeleton
translation she discovered the first
complete fish lizard ever
throughout her life she discovered tons
of fossils and sold rare invertebrates
here by the seashore of england's
jurassic coast
unfortunately mary lived in a time where
men ruled the roost and many of them
routinely took credit for her findings
but even though she might not have
gotten the kudos she deserved while
alive she has gone down in history as
the greatest fossilist the world ever
knew
she was even selected as one of the
three most important female scientists
in britain and inspired a tongue twister
that's won for the history books sally
sells seashells by the seashore no
weren't you listening
mary sold fossils by the seashore
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
animals
[Music]
we're an off-site facility of the
natural history museum that's not open
to the public this is the skull of
humpback whale our collection of marie
mammals is the second largest collection
in north america this hole right here is
where the eye would have been when it
was still alive we have approximately 5
000 specimens and that includes
dolphins whales seals sea lions i
consider myself the current steward of
the collection
i think of the term
whale warehouse as kind of endearing
when people come to the warehouse
definitely
i think the first thing that is noticed
is the smell
it has a musty museum smell
but
because of the marine mammals having a
lot of oils and lipids there's
definitely a smell of rancid oils we
have jars filled with various kinds of
specimens oh yeah this is nice these are
eyeballs
most people i've worn in advance that
you know this is what you need to
understand the place is like you know
it's not tourist
attraction the warehouse has several
different functions and and one
is to serve as a storage facility for
the oversized specimens
but it's also the facility where we
actually prepare new specimens
we're part of the national marine mammal
stranding network
we respond to dead stranded marine
mammals
and most of what we've learned about
these species is a result of studying
them closely
we have specimens that have been around
for decades or even more the collection
really is of international significance
if you're a marine mammal researcher
you've probably been here
some of the recent research includes
things like global climate processes and
and how that has changed over time
i'm a scientist and i'm a little bit
removed from the emotional aspect of
things but i still appreciate the
majesty of these incredibly large
charismatic animals and it's it's
difficult to
not be affected
emotionally
by the kinds of things that we're
setting animals that are on the verge of
extinction
what are we going to do about that
[Music]
for over 200 million years these
creatures have roamed the earth but now
their future is uncertain
this is the american horseshoe crab
[Music]
found along the atlantic coastline of
north america the american horseshoe
crab spends the majority of its time in
shallow waters but comes to shore to
mate
the crab has ten eyes the two most
obvious ones are on the top of its shell
but the others are on the tail and near
the mouth
[Music]
horseshoe crabs are harvested for their
blood which has helped prevent illnesses
across the globe
but with the development of their
natural habitat and over harvesting this
once abundant animal has now seen such a
rapid decline in numbers that they are
considered a vulnerable species
this is the american horseshoe crab
[Music]
you